Good morning guys.
It is still dark.
Nikita is awake.
She's got her fishing
clothes on because we are going fishing.
We are going to Cape Town, Hout Bay
And then we have some guests so Clifton, Nikita's
brother, and also Ross all the way from America.
We call him our American dad.
You ready for fishing?
Ready for fishing.
Let's go!
We are about 10:30 (I think)
minutes away from our location.
And my stomach is in trouble.
So we had some food yesterday - you
can see Nikita here - it's a little bit dark with
the GoPro but she is enjoying this looks like.
I need a toilet and I need a toilet fast.
Houston we have a problem.
Alright, we are here but I don't
care about anything right now.
I'm just looking for a toilet.
I'm going to run.
It's not funny Nikita.
Stop laughing.
Good morning.
Sean.
But I do need a toilet.
I do need the toilet before we go.
Is that okay?
No problem, it's open.
Good morning.
This is our friend Sean.
He's going to take us fishing.
Hooked on Africa, and we're excited.
But I need a toilet first.
We had some some prawn curry
which was not a good idea.
Uh oh.
Hallelujah.
A few moments later.
So much better.
You know, there's two things I just realized.
Never eat prawn curry before you go fishing.
And second, we need to appreciate
toilets and toilet paper a lot more.
You guys ready?
Sign.
You sign.
If we die.
There we go.
Cool.
So this is our boat.
Daniel nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
Wonderful.
Jared, nice to meet you.
Oh, okay so there's the toilet in case I need one.
And these are the fishing rods.
This is going to be an interesting day.
Bonito and Yellow Tail.
Okay, when you ready Sean?
Yeah guys, we'll see you when you
get back, but I'll join you tomorrow.
Thank you Sean.
So this is Dad Ross's first time on the ocean.
First time fishing on the ocean in South Africa.
You ready?
I am ready.
And Clifton and Nikita, they're ready.
They're used to this.
Born ready.
There's a lot of seals here.
Hey, hello, hello.
There's some nice dolphins here.
Just want to show you.
Woooo
Wow.
That is beautiful.
Man that's so nice.
There's a couple of birds here.
So we're just seeing if we can get anything here.
So what are we're doing today is we are at spot
fishing so driving around seeing if we can
see birds or any strange activity and then
we will see what we can get.
Doing your fishy dance.
There you go Nikita.
There you go.
Thank you.
Alright, alright, now I'm ready to catch a Marlin.
Those are huge.
Are you ready Nikita?
So the lines are in.
They're getting ready.
Look at Nikita.
More passion more passion more energy more
energy more fishing more fishing more footwork
more footwork more footwork more footwork.
The lines are in.
If you guys look there,
that's actually Lion's Head.
That's Table Mountain from the other side.
Most of you who know Table Mountain - you know
it's very flat but from this side from the
ocean that's what it looks like.
And that there is Cape Town.
But today we don't care about that.
We care about the fish.
Only fish.
Behind us.
Like 6:00 o'clock.
Whale!
So we came here all the way to the other side.
And you can see Table Mountain now there it is
from this side and then there's
a whale right here visiting us.
The GoPro is never good with
distance, but maybe you can see it.
So take a look at this.
There's so many fish here
but it looks like there's nothing chasing them.
There's a lot of birds here in the sky as well.
Many of them.
So we've been trolling for
a little bit but no bites.
Not yet.
If it's God's
will we'll get something.
It's just a waiting game.
Getting some rest.
Waiting for the fishies.
Fish on!
We finally got a fish!
Yay, got a fish.
Bonito, first one.
I missed it all.
Never eat prawns curried.
The toilet.
Look at that.
This is what we call a Bonito.
Nice Nikita.
Yes!
Well done.
Oh, the other one, you're on.
That's good.
That's good and Clifton is on.
Woo finally it's on.
Hallelujah, hallelujah, hallelujah, got it got it.
Oh, the seals got it.
Oh my goodness.
Jared
Take it on the other side.
Sure Jared.
You're fighting a seal.
Yeah.
Nothing.
Yeah, there's nothing.
There's nothing left of the Bonito.
It's gone.
There goes your fish Clifton.
Next is yours.
Next is mine.
It happens.
The seal.
It's their house not my house.
That's true.
As long as it only went to the seal.
Keep it tight it's all good.
All good.
First fish for him.
Just look where the line is.
So this is Dad Ross's first ever
fish on the ocean.
Wow, awesome.
Come on, oh bring him in.
Bring him in.
We're starting to see.
Here we go.
Your first fish in the sea.
Thank you first fish in the sea.
Not too bad.
Well done.
Thank you.
Stand for a photo.
And now you could also ask
me why it took me so long to find the fish?
You say very different from bass fishing?
Yes, very different.
But it was fun, right?
It was.
Things happen a lot quicker here on the boat.
It does.
That's awesome.
Clifton you have to take the next one.
No, it's your turn.
Get yours.
No that seal took it.
The seal took yours so it's all good.
Nice nice.
Yes.
So the seals are a bit of a problem.
They're following us.
Right there.
We're having some snacks here, some energy bars.
Really really good.
And now it's a bit quiet and I
think I need to go back to the loo.
Because looks like if I go in
there the fish start biting.
Fish on for Clifton.
He lost his earlier so he's got a second.
Go.
Oh the seal is coming, is coming.
Hurry hurry ... really
coming.... he's really coming.
Go go go go come come come come got it.
He's got it.
Ah reel in ... the seal ... reel in the seal.
Let me show you the seal.
Right here.
Oh man.
He's got this one as well.
Tell me if you need any help.
Ok starboard starboard it's got
all the lines and it snapped.
Fishing for me ...
Clifton, second one.
Yeah.
Those creatures are nasty.
They're terrible.
They're thieves.
Yeah the seals, they're a bit of a problem here.
It's near to Robin Island and
there are many seals here.
But, today that's where the fish are.
Who knew the seal was coming.
Who called the seal?
I saw him,
Huh?
Who is the man who called
the seal ...seal to us two?
Yeah got it.
Quick.
The seal got it.
Let me show you.
He got a fish on.
I wanted it to be fast and I thought
if if I'm there first in the water.
Yellow Tail.
That's awesome.
So they're seeing some Yellow Tail in the water.
That's really a tasty fish.
Come on Daniel, come on come on come on.
Fish on.
Fish on come on baby you two stay away.
Yeah hold on hold on.
Yes
Ahhh
Danie?
What happened?
The other lines that's it.
Lost it.
The second one.
The first one to the seal, this one was
just a little bit, yeah little difficult.
So now we're going to go down the list.
The next one is Nikita.
We get a bite.
Jackass Penguins.
Yeah, look at the Jackass Penguins.
Jackass.
You never know what you're going
to get when you're in the ocean.
So now we've seen whale, we've seen dolphins,
we've seen a lot of seals taking our fish but it's
their territory, their land, so it's fine.
Their sea land.
And then some penguins.
This is awesome.
Clifton is checking out the fish there.
You know, this is quite special because
you sit here - it's relaxing - it's out away
from the noise, the bustle of the city life,
and then just look at this view.
Table Mountain there.
Cape Town.
Nikita are you enjoying yourself?
Yeah.
Ross, you enjoying yourself?
Lekker!
Clifton, you're enjoying yourself?
All good.
Looks like Nikita's on.
Oh we on again.
Oh go go go Ross go Ross go Ross that's you.
Go.
One here, come here,
come here you can help take this.
Clifton, go go go go go go.
There you go.
A lot of line.
He's next to you.
Three lines on.
This is fun.
Oh here comes a seal.. whose
fish is he going to eat?
No one's, okay.
Nice.
You also got one.
Well done guys.
One left.
One of those hooks
They got it.
Nice.
Alright, I was reeling and
with a little left, it was off.
Oh man nothing happened.
I went about 5 minutes - nothing.
How's that Nikita?
Oh amazing.
You want to hold the fish?
Sure.
Going to flip so just hold tight... you got it.
I'm going to take a photo of this one can you
hold this hold it tight tight.
He knew I was a Yank (Yankee).
Yeah, alright one two oh
that's a nice one Dad Ross.
Alright, you guys ready?
One two three.
Nikita, yours looks like the biggest one.
I do have the biggest one.
That was mine.
That is mine.
She just picked up the big one.
You just picked up the
Mine was on the silver one
I watched, I watched, yeah I did.
Here we go.
Thank you.
1 2 3 - Hallelujah, long lost.
Awesome.
I'll go quick before they go.
Thank you.
Alright.
Howzit Nikita.
Awesome.
Fist bump.
Well done.
There we go.
So light line come this come this one come this
way away from that line woo yeah it's a lot of lot
of fun come this way come this way.
Yes sir.
Well done.
Jared this way.
Move a little bit that way.
Here comes a seal, here comes a seal.
Who said that?
So fun.
Oh he cut the loop as well.
He got the hook.
Did you get the hook out?
Yeah nice.
And in it goes.
Clifton is on.
Oh the line is under the
boat ooh we've got a runner.
Bring it in Clifton.
Howzit?
Huh?
Oh man this is so much fun.
Caught one of these lines.
He's going to sort it out.
I'm going to go to Clifton.
What do you think you have?
Fish.
Check all the fish.
I'm not sure if you guys can see this but
there's a lot of fish loading here in the water.
Is it getting closer?
Slowly slowly but surely.
I see it yeah we have some color.
Yeah that's why it's so heavy.
Yep, oh it's a Bonito.
There we go.
I've done it.
Like the line.
Well done.
Alright guys that's the last
one we're going to go back home.
We're going to go to a restaurant close by and
then we're going to have some awesome fish.
Wow this is so much fun.
Nice Nikita?
Yeah.
They're right here.
So awesome.
How cool is that?
And look over here.
How's that?
That's so much fun.
They're playing.
You want to come here?
Wow
Woo.
How's that Ross?
Super cool.
So cool.
If you want to come fishing,
just come to South Africa.
Go with Hooked on Africa.
This is beautiful.
Take it in.
It is more and there's many.
Are you enjoying it Nikita?
It's amazing.
I have never seen anything like that.
This is awesome.
Is awesome yeah.
And there you can see Cape Town in the back.
Oh man, so beautiful.
Yeah, you can see them under water as well.
There's a lot of dolphins here all around us
just escorting us back to the harbor.
I mean, what more can you ask for.
Look at these playing.
So awesome.
Are you enjoying yourself Nikita?
Amazing.
A-mazing.
So this has been here for almost 25-30 years.
It was a floating crane that had been tied to
past Cape storms.
In the storm, cable snapped
and it's in its final resting place.
Every time there's a storm we think
it's going to fall over.
She doesn't want to go.
Sure as we come around the front there we can see
something on the back Something about America.
You guys are everywhere.
See, it is written right there - American.
There's a lot of seals here now you
guys will understand why we had to
battle some of them because there's many.
This island's actually not full of the
moment during breeding season it will just
be full of seals, completely full of seals.
Oh, OK.
So there's a lot.
All eating our fish.
Yeah.
Look at that huge one.
Fat.
Oh, the smell.
You guys can't smell this but
it smells like a farm here.
Don't smell too pretty.
Lovely perfume.
Nice.
Alright guys,
we are back here at the harbor and so what we're
going to do is we're going to eat right here and
ask them to prepare the fish for us.
They have a nice lookout restaurant
right here, right over there.
We wanted to do a barbecue but
I don't feel too good still - my stomach - and
so we're just going to eat it here and show you
what the meat looks like.
Guys thank you so much.
That was awesome.
Thank you, see you tomorrow, yes.
No curry tonight.
No no no no for sure.
This is the restaurant right?
Yes.
Yeah you can find it on YouTube.
I believe Sean's going to bring in your fish.
We're going to cook it for you?
Yes, awesome.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Alright, here we go.
Alright guys, here we are.
We have the Bonito and uh let's taste it.
That was fast.
Prepared it very fast.
It's good and Ross you have not tried this before.
I never tried it before but I'm looking
forward to it.
Alright, is it good?
It's so good.
Fresh caught.
Here we go.
Is the moment.
I must have the biggest one, huh?
Sure.
All looks good Daniel.
Well prepared.
And there we go.
Howzit?
Awesome.
Awesome you guys.
Right.
Thank you.
Liking anything else.
No it's all good.
Yeah thank you.
That's it guys.
Thank you for watching.
Subscribe if you haven't done so already.
We bring out weekly videos and then
you will see content like this.
See you next video.
Cheers!